[Music]
let's watch that uh who wants to be a
millionaire clip oh
dude
this all right i don't use this word
often
but this made me cringe okay
like damn i haven't felt cringe like
this in a minute
i can't wait for this all right let me
make it worse for you
he's gonna get this question wrong okay
all right
i remember watching millionaire as a
little kid with regis hosting the show
and it was such a phenomenon 10 million
people watching the show about smart
people every night
celebrating being smart and i thought
you know what wait maybe it's not
bad being smart maybe it's not bad being
a nerd maybe it's cool to be smart
and i followed that all the way and i
just graduated from medical school
that's awesome congratulations
maybe some lingering bills from med
school we need to pay off perhaps
let's take care of that today let's work
on it this is what you're up against 14
questions from 500 all the way up to 1
million dollars of course
it gets the first one wrong let it ride
let it run do you know how those work
yes sir you ready to go
i'm always ready without further ado
let's play
who wants to be a millionaire i hate
this it's like a
[Music]
snapping selfies and kitchens you can't
afford and taking a
meatball break are two things buzzfeed
says
every 20 something does on their first
trip
where to paris to london
to rome to ikea
i'll tell you what i think they do serve
meatballs in ikea
and uh i don't think that's the right
answer though
so kitchens you can't afford meatballs
sounds like it's gotta be rome to me in
fact if i win a million dollars i would
love to take a trip literally
i'm gonna say rome final answer
britney was ikea it was ikea
oh no oh no
oh man so
[Applause]
oh my god
i've never seen some [ __ ] like that in
my entire life
he just talked about how smart he was
for like three minutes
you know this show taught me that it's
okay to be smart and uh so i followed
that through
it was ikea it
was i know ikea has meatballs but uh i
think that's the right answer
rome oh my god dude
oh my god oh my god
[ __ ] hell man see that's the thing
he's smart but
he doesn't [ __ ] okay doesn't know what
it's like to like
hang out with people right do things
right so when it's like
when people socialize they tend to i'm
going to corner and run away
correct answer was conversate
what a fake ass word
was that a quote from me from last
episode yeah in the crowd
fake fake word words dumb yeah
conversate i believe
ikea has meatballs but i mean and he was
so quick with it too he didn't think
at all kitchens you don't own is that
what it said
snap selfies and kitchens you can't
afford
i've never been to ikea my apartment has
one microscope and that's it
and that's for looking at my own b-day
babe not now i'm looking at my b dick
through my microscope
[Laughter]
i can't find it i want to get yoked
by like next year okay buy a microscope
stand butt ass naked in the corner of
our bedroom javelina walk in like two in
the afternoon
what the [ __ ] are you doing ripped ass
back just
yo i'm like just looking at my big bee
dick
just freak her out just become a totally
different balcony from all the steroids
yeah
yeah just looking at my b dick that's
what i strive to be
what those bodybuilders had gold so just
acne everywhere
yeah because they take so much steroids
bro all right that's a hot look
okay okay i have to
on something the bodybuilders have to
bring this up so i'm working on this
video
kind of i'm gonna shoot it but basically
the debate between like vegans and
carnivores i didn't realize how
intense it is to this day okay there's
like whole podcasts
like like when you see horny accounts
for like
i don't know sex memes and stuff there's
the equivalent for like pro-vegan and
pro-carnivore diets and they like
they post [ __ ] like vegan gets
annihilated or
the truth about carnivore whatever right
it's exhausting so [ __ ] weird dude
just eat eat whatever you want like who
gives a [ __ ]
but what i wanna do so i'm gonna make
this video but i'm gonna put this
idea forward in the video and i want to
host a small boxing event
and i want to do the vegans versus
carnivores
so if you're a vegan or a carnivore and
you live in la
and you want to [ __ ] it's either
going gonna be that or i wanna do like a
[ __ ]
triathlon okay where i make vegans and
carnivores like run down some stretch
and then do some other physical thing
and then try to hit like that circus
like mallet to like
send a little thing on top and like see
who does better yeah
and then whoever's angry after that then
make those guys fight that's a good idea
i just i wanna i wanna hold carnivores
versus vegans
i wanna see who's really about it i like
that
yeah so if you're either if you're
either one and you got back knee and
you've done roids
like i'd love it if a dude's like i'm
vegan i take steroids but
yeah i'm down yeah i would love that so
open invitation
damn if you're a psycho for either now
that's you too if you want to rep
if you want to join or represent one
side but i'm not like a a carnivore is
that a person that only eats meat
because people
didn't joe rogan do that for a while
yeah yeah did the all-meat diet
yeah is that what a carnivore is i
believe so yeah and vegan is no animal
products
none okay so you can't be in between no
okay that's why so you got to pick a
side yeah
so what side are you on honestly so i
did a video
about dudes that eat raw meat diets
uh-huh you ever seen that yeah you saw
that yeah i'm just waiting for your
answer to know if we're still friends
that's what i'm on carnivore well raw
carnivore diet
okay are we good we're good okay okay
we're good you're
you're a fellow carney huh yeah we're
good we're good for about 10 more
seconds cause i'm about to [ __ ] you
up dude
oh yeah we're good we're good to fight
[ __ ]
say you like veggies say you love them
see you like lettuce
i'm gonna bring some in the video but i
saw a lady wore a t-shirt in santa
monica that said be kind to animals or
i'll kill you
nice that's [ __ ] awesome and i really
she was she's there smoking a cigarette
yeah and
i was i just so badly want to go up to
her and be like
could you actually though yeah she like
could actually was like you think you
could kill me
i think i would i think i beat the [ __ ]
out of you if i'm being honest
i would love to see you try
yeah that's what i said in the i did
this video about um
like wait you know i just take a dog and
put in a trash can in front of her do it
go for it do something do it kill me go
you